ya vimos que las fracciones de este tipo
como dos quintos pueden representarse
literalmente como dos por un quinto dos
por un quinto que es lo mismo es igual a
tener literalmente dos quintos un quinto
más un quinto si queremos visualizar lo
tenemos aquí un entero que dividimos en
cinco partes en cinco partes iguales y
esto representa dos de estos quintos
este es el primer quinto y el segundo
quinto literalmente dos quintos dos
quintos ahora pensemos en algo más
interesante que se da tres por dos
quintos y los invitó a que pausa en el
vídeo y haga en esta operación por
ustedes mismos con base en lo que
acabamos de hacer acá piensen ustedes a
que sería igual esto pues acabamos de
ver que dos quintos es lo mismo en lugar
de tres por dos quintos escrito así como
está voy a poner
el tres por dos por un quinto que es lo
mismo que dos quintos dos por un quinto
y como de multiplicación podemos
multiplicar tres por un quinto y después
multiplicarlo por dos o podemos
multiplicar el tres por el dos primero y
después multiplicarlo por un quinto
podemos ver esto como 3 por 2 6 lo
escribimos aquí 6 por un quinto 6 por un
quinto ahora visualmente vamos a poner
esta unidad o este entero y agregamos
otro entero igual con las mismas
divisiones así que tenemos dos enteros
cada uno dividido en cinco partes
iguales y vamos a colorear nuestros seis
puntos primer quinto segundo quinto
tercer quinto cuarto quinto quinto
quinto
sexto quinto así que literalmente tres
por dos quintos es seis puntos y por
supuesto seis por un quinto son seis
quintos 6 aisló cambio de color 6 entre
5 6 quintos y a lo mejor ustedes me
dicen bueno en lugar de ver esto como 2
por un quinto como lo vimos acá porque
no vemos dos quintos como un síntoma son
quinto vamos a ver así que tres por dos
quintos lo reescribimos de nuevo aquí
abajo tres por dos entre cinco o dos
quintos es lo mismo que tres x
un quinto más un quinto dos quintos es
lo mismo que un quinto más un quinto así
que lo escribimos hacia aquí abajo un
quinto más un quinto que va a ser igual
a pues tendremos literalmente tres
grupos de un quinto más un quinto cada
uno un quinto más un quinto cierra
paréntesis más un quinto más un quinto
cerramos suma abrimos paréntesis bueno
creo que aquí ya se están dando cuenta
de qué es lo que va a pasar un quinto
más un quinto se cierra paréntesis y que
va a ser esto pues aquí lo que tenemos
son seis quintos podemos ignorar los
paréntesis ya que estamos sumando todo
así que tenemos uno dos tres cuatro
cinco seis seis quintos así que de nuevo
tenemos el mismo resultado espero que
esto les haya ayudado a comprender que
estos dos quintos que escribimos aquí
representados por un quinto y a su vez
es la suma de un quinto más un quinto y
tres por dos quintos es exactamente
igual a tres por dos por un quinto que
es seis quintos